para este momento ya tienen bastante
noción de lo que es la multiplicación de
escribir aquí multi
click
ocasión
y en este vídeo lo que vamos a buscar es
que ustedes empiecen poco a poco a
memorizar sus tablas de multiplicar si
ustedes ven más vídeos adelante en khan
academy se van a dar cuenta que no
buscamos que memoricen sino que razonen
sin embargo les prometo que si ustedes
se aprenden sus tablas de multiplicar
bueno la vida va a ser mucho más
sencilla no quiero prometer que en todos
los aspectos de su vida pero sí sería
mucho más fácil si se saben las tablas
de multiplicar que si no se lo supieran
ok bueno en este vídeo entonces como les
decía vamos a tener un tanto de práctica
y vamos a ver las tablas de multiplicar
y vamos a razonar cuáles son los
patrones en los que vienen y empezaremos
entonces definiendo que el multiplicar
sería decir cuántas veces tengo un
número por sí mismo o sumando así
asimismo un ejemplo tenemos cuánto es 2
por 1 y esto está muy sencillo me está
diciendo que el número 2 solo lo tendré
una vez
este es el número que estoy teniendo y
este por cuántas veces lo estoy teniendo
sólo lo tenemos por uno entonces dos por
uno es igual a dos que pasa cuando tengo
dos por dos
esto implica que tendré dos
dos veces en dos lo tendré dos veces y
será una dos veces si hacemos esta suma
tenemos dos más dos es igual a cuatro
vamos bien ahora tenemos dos por tres
ustedes ya saben qué significa cada
posición tenemos el número 2 que estará
repetido tres veces eso será el 2 una
vez el 2 2 veces el 2 3 veces o también
podemos pensarlo lo pondré con otro
color como el 3 2 veces
+ 3 una vez dos veces de cualquier
manera esto cuánto sumarán tendremos dos
más 24 más 26
o 33 es igual a 6 vamos a hacer esto
hasta digamos el número 10 o 12 que son
básicamente los números que ocupan
aprender se sale y entonces vamos a ver
ahora tenemos dos por cuatro ustedes me
dirán que tendré el 2 repetido cuatro
veces
o si lo queremos representar de la otra
manera tendremos el 4 cuantas veces 2 4
y 4 aquí lo que me interesa que vean es
esto que este interesantísimo tenemos 2
más 2 más 2 más 2
se dan cuenta aquí arriba ya teníamos 2
más 2 más 2 y esto nos dio 6
ok
esto nos dio 6 y aquí abajo lo tenemos
de nuevo tenemos 2 más 2 más 2 y sabemos
que esto es 6
así es que nuestro resultado será ese 6
más 26 más 2 es igual a 8
y lo interesante aquí es esto nosotros
del dos por uno teníamos dos
y el siguiente resultado fue 2 por 2 se
fue a 4 lo que hicimos fue sumarle 2
lo ven
del 4 al 6 volvimos a sumar 2
del 6 al 8 sumamos 2 así es que este es
el patrón que se repite en la tabla de
multiplicar del 2
podemos hacerlo más rápido de hecho
entonces tendremos 2 x 5 y esto será
igual a podemos escribir tal vez el 2
más 2 más 2 más 2 más 2
el 25 veces o el 52 veces
55 y podemos llegar al resultado de las
dos maneras o sumándole al 82
o contando estos ocho más dos es igual a
22 42 62 82 10 es el mismo resultado 55
10 vamos a regresar a los colores
originales
ahora tenemos 2 x 6
y puedo escribir seis veces el 2
cuando llegamos 1 2 3 4 5 6
o puedo poner
dos veces el 6
o simplemente puedo sumarle al día
anterior
de cualquier manera vamos a tener 12 2 2
4 6 8 10 12 6 6 12 hagamos uno más
2 x 7
esto cada vez se vuelve más cansado y
más largo
2 4 5 6 7
o dos veces 777 o como lo hemos hecho
anteriormente al 12 le sumaremos 2 y de
cualquier manera tendremos como
resultado 14
vamos un poco más rápido
2 x 8 será 14 2 16
2 x 9
16 20 18
hagamos un poco más de espacio
no era mucho porque quiero que vean todo
todo lo que hemos trabajado tendremos
dos por diez
y este número este interesantísimo
porque van a ver un patrón aquí muy
interesante 18 2 tendremos 20 y si se
dan cuenta
tenemos el 2 este 2 es este 2 y el 10
nos representa un 0 porque tenemos dos
dieces 10 10
10 + 10 por lo tanto van a ver el patrón
en el que el número multiplicado por
diez lo que hará es sumarle un cero a la
derecha
lo ven el 2 y el 10
hagamos un par más que son les decía los
que más utilizarán 2 por 11
será 20 2 igual a 22
2 x 12 será igual a muy bien 24 porque
le sumaron a estos 22 2 más
ya tienen claramente el patrón
y esta es la tabla del 2 y ustedes de
verdad van a tener que practicar
muchísimo las tablas del 2 del 3 del 4
así varias de ellas y sobre todo al
tenerlos en la cabeza memorizados va a
ser muchísimo más sencillo vamos a hacer
una cosa vamos a escribir una tabla
de multiplicar y haremos más espacio
aquí abajo
para que podamos hacerlo
lo haré lo más grande que pueda y lo que
nos quepa en nuestro espacio ok vamos a
hacer una tabla les decía de este lado
pondré una columna
con el 12
10 lo haré hasta el 10 ustedes pueden y
deberían hacerlo más grande yo
simplemente les voy a enseñar cuál es el
patrón y ustedes para convertirse en
todos los expertos en las tablas y
practicar y practicar hágalo más
adelante hagan de 11 de 12 así y por
este lado haré una fila con los mismos
números 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
no pondré el cero porque finalmente si
ustedes multiplican cualquier número por
cero será cero ok eso es importante que
lo sepan cualquier número que tengan por
cero siempre será cero
lo que vamos a hacer es multiplicar el
número de la fila por el número de la
columna es decir uno por uno y aquí
abajo colocaré el resultado vamos a
ponerlo con distintos colores para que
esto sea como más divertido y tengan
muchas opciones de dónde de dónde verlos
aunque empezaremos con este color azul
que ya tenemos aquí
uno por uno es una vez tener el uno y
con eso tendremos uno
uno por dos es tener una vez el número
1 x 3
1 por 44 de hecho es muy sencilla la
tabla del uno porque cualquier número x
uno
siempre será ese mismo número 1 por 11 1
por 2 21 por 3 31 por 44 así es que
puedo saber que uno por 5 51 por 6 61
por 7 71 por 8 81 por 99 1 por 10
ya cumplimos con el primer renglón que
es la tabla del 1 vamos entonces a
cambiar colores y ahora haremos la tabla
del 2
voy a resaltarlo y lo haremos de la
siguiente manera todos por 1 2
2 x 2 es decir dos veces el 2 será 4
2 x 3
si yo tengo el 23 veces o el 32 veces
tendré 6 y aquí está el mismo patrón que
habíamos visto hace un momento estamos
incrementando de dos en dos cada vez que
avanzamos en nuestra tabla de
multiplicar 2 por 48
2 x 5 10 2 por 6 12
2 por 7 14
2 x 8 será si le sumamos este 2 será 16
2 x 9 sumamos otros 218
2 por 1020
vamos bien cambiemos el color ahora
anaranjado
vamos con el 3 y si nosotros tenemos 3
por 1 es lo mismo que decir 1 por 3
lo ven y este sí lo tenemos uno por tres
es igual a tres
por lo tanto 3 por 1 que es lo mismo
será igual a 3
esta vez aumentaremos cada vez de 3 en 3
estamos multiplicando por tres son
múltiplos de 3 3 por 2 6 y lo tenemos
también aquí 3 por 2 es igual a dos por
tres tenemos seis son exactamente el
mismo número lo ven 3 por 3 será igual a
9 estamos sumando 3 unidades en cada
avance que tenemos 3 por 4 12 3 por 5 15
3 por 6 18
es por 721 3 por 824
estamos sumando 3
3 por 927 3 por 10 30
aquí se ve el mismo patrón que decíamos
hace un momento
estamos en la tabla del 3 y
multiplicamos por 10 tenemos un 3 con un
0 a la derecha añadido
vámonos con el 4 hagamos esto de color
morado 4
44 por 1 41 por 44
44 por 28
2 por 48
4 x 3 12
4 x 3 12 3 x 4 12
y ahora sumaremos de cuatro en cuatro en
cada uno de los avances que tengamos en
nuestra tabla de multiplicar 4 por 4 16
4 por 5 20 4 por 6 24 4 por 7 28
4 por 832 estamos sumándole 4 28 129 28
21 30 28 más 3 son 31 y 28 más 4 son 32
4 x 9 36 y 4 x 10 40 vamos a tomar un
poco más de velocidad 5 hagamos el 5
este lo pondré en rojo porque me
divierte mucho ustedes verán es muy
fácil la tabla del 55 por 15 una vez
tenemos 55 por 210
5 por 3 15 y esto es lo que me resulta
divertido y fácil de aprender porque la
tabla del 5 irá avanzando de cinco en
cinco así es que tendremos un número
terminado en cinco o un número
terminando en cero un número terminando
el 5 un número terminando en cero
y así seguiremos sumando de 5 en 5 5 por
4 25 por 5 25 5 por 6 35 por 7 35 5 por
8 45 por 9 45 5 por 10 50 jóvenes estuvo
divertido y ahora con amarillo haremos
con amarillo la tabla del 66 por 16 por
lo que es lo mismo 1 por 6
6 x 2 12 por lo que es lo mismo 2 por 6
12 6 por 3 18
6 x 4 24
6 x 5 30
6 x 6 36
6 x 7 42
6 x 8 48
6 x 9 54 sólo estamos sumando de seis en
seis en el avance 6 por 10 60 creo que
me estoy quedando sin colores voy a
hacer la tabla del 7 con blanco y creo
que repetiremos colores más arriba 7 por
si a 7 le sumó 7 otra vez tendré 7 por 2
14 14 7 por 2 o 2 por 7 7 por 3 es igual
a 21
7 por 4 28
7 x 5 35 7 por 6 42 si le suma 42 7
tendré 49
7 x 8 56 eso es importante yo me solía
confundir muchísimo con el 56 aprendan
selo siempre siempre lo preguntan 7 x 8
56 7 x 9 63
y 7 por 10 70
8 x 18
8 por 2 16 8 por 3 24 van sumando
ustedes lo importante es que ustedes
vayan viendo y vayan razonándolo y lo
vayan sumando junto conmigo ok 8 por 4
8 por 5 48 por 6 48 de hecho lo podemos
ver 8 por 6
es lo mismo que 6 por 8 48 lo ven 48 58
8 por 7 56 este es el mismo que les
decía que a mí me costaba mucho trabajo
7 por 8 156 que es lo mismo que 8 por 7
8 por 8 64 8 por 9 72 y 8 x 1080 un par
más que nos cupo nuestra tabla bastante
bien aquí veamos si queda diferente
muy poco pero si se ve
9 x 19 9 x 2 18 9 por 3 27
de hecho ojo aquí pueden verlo muy fácil
pareciera que voy a sumarle 10 si
tuvieran 9 10 serían 19 pero le quitó
118 si a 18 le sumará 10 tendría 28 pero
le quito 127 poco a poco lo van a ver en
otros vídeos embargo me parecía
interesante que lo que lo notaran aquí 9
por 4 36 9 por 5 45
9 x 6 es igual a 54 9 por 7 súmenle 9 a
54 63 9 por 8 sumen sumen sumen aquí
tendremos 72 9 por 9 es igual a 81 y 9
por 10 es igual a 90 nosotros sólo
estamos haciendo estas tablas pero son
infinitas vaya ustedes no hay un número
más grande están de acuerdo pueden
multiplicar 1 por 10 por un millón por
200 millones por lo que ustedes gusten
lo importante es que teniendo estas
tablas básicas ustedes poco a poco
tengan muchísimo mayor práctica y de
esta manera puedan aprender selo así
bueno hacer mucho más sencilla las
operaciones en un futuro vamos a hacer
el último y lo colocaré con este color
que está muy romántico 10 10 x 1 10 10 x
220 estamos sumando de 10 en 10 10 por 3
30 10 por 4 40 10 por 5 50 10 por 660 10
por 7 70 10 por 8 80 10 por 990 y 10 por
bien en este momento creo que ya
llevamos un vídeo bastante largo pero es
importante que lo tengan a la mano voy a
volver a marcar cuáles son las
diferencias en estas líneas
listo por el momento lo único que les
pudiera decir es aprenderse esto
memoricen sus tablas de multiplicar
razones porque cada una cambia en qué
cantidad
y con esto realmente llegarán muy muy
lejos para las siguientes operaciones y
todo lo que viene de matemáticas en su
vida
en un vídeo más adelante haremos tablas
tal vez más allá del 10 y tendremos más
práctica nos vemos pronto